Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications, and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful, and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get on to the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the
嗨，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家集体》这本书来帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我真的很高兴我这么做了。看到其他人对他们心路历程的反思是如此具有启发性，这也让我对自己的心路历程和技能进行了很多反思。它还帮助我调整了心态，提醒我如果今年没有考上博士也没关系。然而，这本书最让我意想不到的惊喜是，每个人的心路历程都是如此鼓舞人心。每天把这些故事作为我早晨的动力，真是一种享受。我甚至有点舍不得看到
end. What if one of the most powerful tools for girls' confidence was hiding there in plain sight on the school timetable. Today I'm joined by Dr. Mel Morrison, aka the Sporty Ed Psych. And we are talking about why girls in sport isn't just about fitness. It's about emotional regulation, identity, belonging, resilience. And crucially, how inclusive access to sport can actually help girls to thrive in education. Because when girls feel strong somewhere, it changes how they show up everywhere. I hope you'll find this episode really helpful. If you do, please like, comment and subscribe for more. Hi, I just want to welcome you along to the podcast. Today I'm joined by Dr. Mel Morrison, the sporty ed psych. Lovely to have you here, Mel, thanks for joining us. Thanks for having me,
这本书的结尾。女孩自信心最强大的工具之一，会不会就大喇喇地隐藏在学校的课程表里呢？今天，我和人称“运动型教育心理学家”的梅尔·莫里森博士（Dr. Mel Morrison）一起来到节目中。我们将探讨为什么女孩参与运动不仅仅是为了健身。它还关乎情绪调节、身份认同、归属感和韧性。最重要的是，包容性的运动参与实际上如何帮助女孩在教育中茁壮成长。因为当女孩在某个地方感到坚强时，这会改变她们在所有地方的表现。希望大家会觉得这一集非常有用。如果你喜欢，请点赞、评论并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，我想欢迎大家收听本期播客。今天和我一起的是运动型教育心理学家梅尔·莫里森博士。很高兴你能来，梅尔，谢谢你加入我们。谢谢邀请我，
looking forward to getting into the discussion. Absolutely. And it's a really interesting one today. Why does it matter that girls get into sport and exercise? Why is that a good thing? thing for their kind of psychological development, would you say? Yeah. So a really big topic at the moment is girls in sports. And it is absolutely brilliant, in my opinion,
我很期待接下来的讨论。绝对的。今天的讨论非常有趣。为什么女孩参与体育运动和锻炼如此重要？你会说，这对她们的心理发展有什么好处呢？是的。所以目前一个非常热门的话题就是女孩参与运动。在我看来，这绝对是极其精彩的，
for their psychological development, because it gives them a completely different lens to see themselves. There are so many benefits. So you think about emotional urban development. So sports just gives young people, our girls, a platform to, you know, to. express emotions to recognize different emotions. So for example, you know, intense joy, anger,
对她们的心理发展大有裨益，因为它为她们提供了一个完全不同的视角来审视自己。这有非常多的好处。比如，你可以想想情绪发展的过程。运动为年轻人、我们的女孩提供了一个平台，让她们能够表达情绪，识别不同的情绪。例如，强烈的喜悦、愤怒、
frustration, excitement, confusion, you know, they're allowed to be expressed and we almost expect it to be expressed in a sport, sport based domain. But it also allows girls to learn how to regulate those emotions as well. You know, it's brilliant to express these emotions in a variety of different depending on which sport is chosen, but also we're able to learn how to regulate in a safe and structured way, which is really healthy than having big emotions just stuck in our mind and no outlet. Socially, in terms of, you know, girls' development, sports allows for a sense of belonging, which is really important in this day and age where a lot of young girls struggle with loneliness and feeling isolated. Sports allows us to be with others, to socially connect, to have shared goals.
沮丧、兴奋、困惑，你知道的，这些情绪在以运动为基础的领域里是被允许表达的，而且我们几乎期望它们能在这里表现出来。但它同时也让女孩们学会了如何调节这些情绪。你知道，在不同的体育项目中表达这些情绪是非常棒的（这取决于所选择的运动），但我们也能学到如何在安全和结构化的方式中进行调节，这比把巨大的情绪闷在心里却没有宣泄口要健康得多。从社交角度来看，就女孩的发展而言，运动能带来一种归属感，在这个许多年轻女孩挣扎于孤独和孤立感的时代，这一点尤为重要。运动让我们能与他人相处、进行社交联系、拥有共同的目标。
You know, for example, being part of a gym class or a running club or a team sport. You're with your peers, you're with consistent coaches on a weekly daily basis, building those social bonds, developing social interaction skills, which is really important, you know, in life, work, development and growing up. Another reason is for, you know, girls' identity and confidence, you know, if you think about the teenage girl, adolescence is that period of time where they're really struggling with their identity. There are so many pressures and stresses going on in their lives. You know, they're figuring out who they are and, you know, why they matter and who they matter to, where they belong. There are so many challenges that, you know, we hear in media around, you know, body image, you know,
例如，参加健身课、跑步俱乐部或团队运动。你和同龄人在一起，每周每天都有稳定的教练陪伴，建立这些社交纽带，培养社交互动技能，这在生活、工作、个人发展和成长中真的非常重要。另一个原因是为了女孩的身份认同和自信，如果你想想十几岁的女孩，青春期正是她们极力挣扎于自我认同的时期。她们的生活中承受着如此多的压力和负担。她们在弄清楚自己是谁，为什么重要，对谁重要，以及自己属于哪里。我们从媒体上听到关于女孩的各种挑战，比如身材焦虑，
with girls, our girls today are living in a time of filters and selfies and what the ideal body is, you know, achievement culture, you know, wanting to do well in school, a lot of social media comparison and just the pressure to have it all, have it all, you know, be sporty, be academically bright, have a have a good body, meet society's standards. But sports is, you know, one of the places where that is a, lessened and it's not about looks and academics. It's about performance. It's about fulfillment. It's about learning new skills. You know, the narrative is changed. You know, I recognize that that might not be automatic, but, you know, in terms of that, that's really powerful. It's about look at what I can do, look at where I can belong, look at what I can tolerate, which is really
如今的女孩生活在一个充满滤镜、自拍和追求完美身材的时代，还有成就文化——想要在学校里表现优秀，大量的社交媒体比较，以及必须拥有一切的压力：既要热爱运动、学业优秀，又要身材好，还要符合社会的标准。但运动是其中一个能够减轻这种压力的地方，它不看外表和学历。它关乎表现。关乎成就感。关乎学习新技能。叙事方式改变了。我承认这可能不是自动实现的，但就此而言，这是非常有力量的。它是关于“看我能做什么，看我能属于哪里，看我能忍受什么”，这真的
important. I think sports also is brilliant for, you know, just developing that resilience, you know, how to handle discomfort, you know, how to overcome, how to be mentally tough, you know, these are the skills that we want to see later on in life. And also just in terms of development, it's just about, you know, sports is a way to have joy and to have play. You know, try something new, laugh and have fun. You know, it's not always competitive. But there are those elements too. And I think all of those things are, you know, really important for girls to experience. Yeah. Yeah, they certainly are. And, you know, listening to your talk is really making me reflect on on the opportunities that certainly I'm
非常重要。我认为运动对于培养这种韧性也极其出色，比如如何应对不适，如何克服困难，如何变得心理坚韧，这些都是我们希望在未来生活中看到的技能。此外，就发展而言，运动只是一种体验快乐和玩耍的方式。尝试新事物，欢笑并享受乐趣。它并不总是充满竞争的。但其中也有这些元素。我认为所有这些体验对女孩来说都非常重要。是的。是的，确实如此。而且，听你这么说，真的让我反思了那些机会，当然，
speaking as a 44-year-old woman, the opportunities that weren't really around for me as a teenager. And, you know, those shoulds and those shouldn't, like, that's maybe not for you. And it made me reflect on, you know, when the Olympics were in London, London, 2012. And at the time, I was just about to get married. So I was a qualified psychologist, very excited. And the poll vaulting really spoke to me. And I was like, oh, I think I was 31, 32, maybe at the time, something like that. And I was like, oh, isn't that incredible?
作为一个44岁的女性，我可以说，这些机会在我十几岁的时候其实并不存在。还有那些“你应该”和“你不应该”，比如，“那个可能不适合你”。这让我想起了2012年伦敦奥运会举办的时候。当时，我正准备结婚。所以我是一名合格的心理学家，非常兴奋。撑竿跳高这个项目深深地吸引了我。当时我想，噢，我可能31、32岁左右吧，差不多那个年纪，我就在想，天哪，这太不可思议了！
And I was like, I never, I've never poll voted. Like, I seem to remember there was that kind of equipment at school, but it was never offered to me. I've never had a chance to do that. And I just think it's a real shame. So I might never have been an Olympian pole vault, although my family do wind me up and like, oh, Marianne, the pole vaulting's all, you still haven't done it. And now I've had two cesarean sections, and I'm 44. So probably I'm not going to be winning any gold medals.
然后我想，我从来——我从来没有练过撑竿跳。我依稀记得学校里好像有那种器材，但从来没有人向我提供过这个机会。我从来没有机会去尝试。我只是觉得这真的很遗憾。所以我也许永远成不了奥运会撑竿跳选手，尽管我的家人经常开玩笑调侃我，说：“玛丽安，撑竿跳还在那儿呢，你还是没去跳。”而现在我已经经历过两次剖腹产了，而且44岁了。所以大概我是不会赢得什么金牌了。
But shouldn't we be encouraging everyone? to have a go kind of at everything, especially if the equipment's already there, right? Yeah, absolutely. I think, you know, the narrative around sports is changing and it's not just saved for those who want to be highly competitive or who are naturally skilled. We are, you know, sports is trying to reach those who just want to have fun, who just want to feel a sense of empowerment, who just want to feel, you know, want to explore new skills, who want to just try new things and those things aren't bad. You know, I think we've gotten into a poor narrative of if you're not competitive, then, you know, you shouldn't be taking part. But, you know, in terms
但是，难道我们不应该鼓励每个人去尝试各种事情吗？特别是如果器材已经摆在那里的话，对吧？是的，绝对的。我认为，围绕体育运动的叙事正在改变，它不再仅仅留给那些渴望极具竞争力或天生擅长运动的人。我们在努力让体育触及那些只想获得快乐、只想感受到赋权、只想探索新技能、只想尝试新事物的人，而这些并不是坏事。你知道，我认为我们陷入了一种糟糕的叙事中：如果你不具备竞争力，那么你就不应该参与。但是，就
of who it's reached, and I think that's definitely widening, the narrative is changing. You know, if you didn't start off with a sporty background in your younger years, you know, one thing I am loving seeing is, you know, women or girls later on getting involved and just that narrative completely shifting and watching them just have fun. And, you know, and explore what their bodies can do, which is empowering but all by itself. And you know, I think when you're when you're older as well, the motivation changes for sport. You know, you've chosen it because you want to do it. You know, you've made the time for it. You know, life looks a bit different. You know,
它的受众而言，我认为这绝对在拓宽，叙事正在改变。如果你年轻时并没有一个运动背景，你知道，我最喜欢看到的一点是，女性或女孩在稍大一些时参与进来，这种叙事完全发生了转变，看着她们只是在享受乐趣。而且，去探索她们的身体能做些什么，这本身就是一种赋权。你知道，我认为当你年龄大一些的时候，参与运动的动力也会改变。你选择它是出于你想做。你为它腾出了时间。生活看起来有些不同了，
you might have, you might have had children in your younger years and now you've got the capacity to pour back into yourself and just, you know, try and belong to, you know, new clubs, new people. So I think, yeah, I think that's Right? Yeah. And I have been a member of gyms at different points in my life. The first time I was an aspiring psychologist, I think I was in my early 20s. And it was really something that felt like a punishment. It was not something that felt like joy. I didn't build it into my routine. It was definitely that sense of should. And it's only really when I got to 39 and it was kind of pandemic times. I took myself out running and then ultimately,
你可能在年轻时生了孩子，现在你有了精力去回馈自己，去结交新的俱乐部、新的人。所以我想，是的，我觉得是这样，对吧？是的。我在人生的不同阶段也办过健身房会员卡。第一次我立志成为一名心理学家时，我想我二十岁出头。那真的感觉像是一种惩罚，而不是一种快乐。我没有把它融入我的日常生活中。那绝对是一种“应该”去做的感觉。直到我39岁，正值疫情期间，我开始自己出去跑步，最终，
started doing that every day. And I was never a very good runner, but I really liked the way it made my body feel afterwards. And, you know, it really helped me feel good and help me have that time for myself during a really wild time for the world. And then ultimately, after the pandemic, I spotted an advert for a personal trainer. And I thought, well, she looks amazing. Like, I'll have a session with her. And I went into the gym and I looked around and it was all. weight smell and I thought oh no I've made a horrible mistake this is not for me this is awful I thought it was going to be treadmills and you know elliptical trainers and sit-ups and I thought this is horrendous yeah and so very
开始每天都坚持跑步。我从来都不是一个跑步好手，但我真的很喜欢它让我的身体在事后感觉到的那种状态。而且，它确实让我感觉很好，在那个对世界来说非常疯狂的时期，帮我赢得了属于自己的时间。后来，在疫情结束后，我看到了一则私人教练的广告。我想，哇，她看起来太棒了。我也要跟她上一节课。于是我走进健身房，环顾四周，到处都是
accidentally I'm still strength training four years later because I loved it and yet I never would have chosen that for myself and it's it's changed my life so I'm now 44 and I said just before we met I've rejiged my whole day today to go to a gym class that I really, really love. I've straightened my hair on the hop, I've deswetted myself, and I'm here because it's just different. I was driving to the gym the other day and the motorway was closed and I was like, oh no. And I'm going to have to try and think of another way to get to the gym and I'm just going to drive around this roundabout while I think about that. And I thought, if I really want to go,
非常偶然地，四年后我仍然在进行力量训练，因为我太喜欢它了。然而我绝不会为自己主动选择这项运动，它改变了我的生活。所以我现在44岁了，就在我们见面之前，我重新调整了今天的整个日程，去上了一堂我真的、真的很喜欢的健身课。我匆忙地把头发拉直，擦干了身上的汗，然后来到了这里，因为这感觉太不一样了。前几天我开车去健身房，高速公路封路了，我当时想：“噢不，我得想别的路去健身房了，我一边想一边在这个环岛转悠。”然后我想，如果我真的想去，
I really want to go. It was a Wednesday evening. I thought, because I've got a busy life and I've got two children. If I don't go, it's not like there's an easy opportunity for me to go a different time. So I just had my brain thinking, I thought, oh, this is different because Marianne in her 20s and early 30s would have treated this as a gift from God to not go and to go and to go and sit and say, well, I tried, but I'm like, no, I really value this time and this chance to move my body And that's the shift, you know, it's never too late, right? If I discovered this in my, in my late 30s, early 40s, there's always opportunity. Yeah, I think it's amazing that you've embedded sports and fitness into your daily routine
我是真的很想去啊。那是星期三的晚上。我想，因为我的生活很忙，还有两个孩子。如果我不去，也没有什么轻松的机会让我改天再去。所以我转念一想，我觉得这太不一样了，因为20多岁和30岁出头的玛丽安会把这当成上帝赐予的礼物——正好可以不用去了，然后找个地方坐下说：“好吧，我试过了。”但我不会，我真的很珍惜这段时间和活动身体的机会。这就是转变，对吧？永远不会太晚！如果我在30多岁末、40多岁初才发现这一点，机会总是有的。是的，我觉得你能把运动和健身融入日常生活，这太棒了，
because I think it's, you know, something that's easily pushed to the side when we've got a lot of competing priorities and we've got lots of different stresses, lots of different demands. And that's definitely something I relate to, you know, in terms of what sports gives me in terms of the emotional regulation, the structure to my day, the peace of mind, you know, just a space to think and keeping my mind clear, especially working as a psychologist when we're constantly thinking about children in different cases, different lifestyles. I think having that blocked out is really important for wellbeing. And I love what you had mentioned about you just trying strengths-based style training. You know, we've
因为当我们要应对许多相互冲突的优先事项、各种不同的压力和需求时，这绝对是很容易被抛到脑后的一件事。这绝对是我能产生共鸣的地方——运动带给我的情绪调节、为我的一天带来的结构感、内心的平静，以及一个可以思考、保持思维清晰的空间，尤其是作为一名心理学家，我们无时无刻不在思考着儿童和各种案例、不同的生活方式。我认为腾出这段时间对身心健康真的很重要。我特别喜欢你刚才提到的话题，你尝试了以力量为基础的训练。你知道，我们在
come a long way with that because there has been a really like poor narrative around women lifting weights and women shouldn't, you know, shouldn't be lifting weights because they will look X, Y and Z or it's been feminine or, you know, our culture has kind of dictated what, you know, the ideal feminine woman is supposed to be and, you know, for so long women have been afraid of, you know, wanting to be strong. But I love that you have decided to, you just decided to take a chance because sport, you know, strengths training is me, it's my heart really. And I think the sense of the pride, the accomplishment, the achievement. And if you think back to, you know, psychological theory around perma well-being and how important it is to feel that sense of
这方面已经取得了长足的进步，因为过去关于女性举重一直存在一种糟糕的叙事。人们认为女性不应该举重，因为那样她们会练成这样或那样的身材，那不够女性化。或者我们的文化一直在规定所谓的“理想女性”应该是什么样子的。长久以来，女性一直害怕表现出想要变强壮的愿望。但我喜欢你决定去冒险尝试，因为运动——力量训练是我的心头好，真的。我想那种自豪感、成就感和达成感，如果你回想起关于PERMA幸福感的心理学理论，就会发现感受到这种成就感是多么重要，而我在运动中获得的这种感觉（听起来你也是），对我们的幸福感大有裨益。所以我太喜欢这个了。
accomplishment and a sense of achievement that I do get, and it sounds like you get from sports, you know, contributes to our well-being. So I love that. Absolutely. And do you know who was right all along but got a lot of flack for it? So I grew up in Spice Girls' Ear. Mel C was an aerosopter for sporty spice wasn't she and I think she did lift weights and she was strong and she did flip and she you know at the time she was many times told that's not feminine that's not okay this isn't okay for girls and it's actually I actually messaged her the other day on Instagram she hasn't respond to us Mel you you were right yeah I'm she was ahead of the game
绝对的。你知道谁一直都是对的却因此挨了很多骂吗？我是在辣妹组合（Spice Girls）的时代长大的。梅尔C（Mel C）不是“辣妹”中的运动辣妹（Sporty Spice）吗？我想她确实举重了，她很强壮，她会做后空翻。当时她曾多次被告知：“那不够女性化，这不对劲，这不适合女孩。”实际上，我前几天还在Instagram上给她发了私信（她还没回复我们）：“梅尔，你是对的。”是的，她走在了时代的前沿。
And I'm sorry I wasn't ready for that message then, but you know, she's still, she must be 50 now. She looks incredible. Incredible. Yeah. Absolutely. You know, you say sport and you've got the image in your head of the tomb, you know, the tomboy. And just how hard society try, you know, they've pumped that message because, you know, we still think about it today. And it was just, you know, everything in your power to not be that.
我很抱歉我当时没有准备好接受那个信息，但你知道，她现在一定50岁了吧？她看起来状态好得不可思议，简直不可思议。绝对的。你知道，当你提到运动时，你的脑海中就会浮现出假小子（tomboy）的形象。社会是多么拼命地试图灌输这种观念，因为直到今天我们依然能想到它。为了不成为那样的人，你简直要竭尽全力。
But now I think, you know, we're with things are looking good. And I think we've got so many role models, women in sport who are speaking out, being more visible, acting as role models that, you know, really are changing the game. And you know, women are, women are stepping out. Girls are stepping out. We just need, you know, everybody else to follow us and believe in us too and give us the opportunities as well. Yeah. And strong can be sexy, right?
但现在我认为，情况正在好转。我们拥有如此多的榜样——那些敢于发声、更加显眼、充当榜样的女性运动员，她们真的在改变游戏规则。女性正在走出来，女孩们正在走出来。我们只需要其他人也跟随我们、相信我们，并给予我们同样的机会。是的，强壮也可以是性感的，对吧？
Strong can be so inspiring. And, you know, it was like, oh, we don't get too mussely or don't get too strong or too thin. You know, men won't want you or, you know, if you're interested in ladies, no one will want you. And it's like, actually, I'm doing this for me. It doesn't really matter what anyone else thinks about me. The right person for me, or maybe people, if we're like keeping our options open, will love me for me. And they want to be with me because I'm incredible, not because they think I do or don't look the right way. Absolutely, which is again, you know, why visibility, you know, of powerful, strong and having, you know, women in sports, you know, all shapes, sizes, body types is so important so that, you know, girls, you know, women, girls are age and younger, you know, our view of sports and what it allows us to do and it allows us to feel, you know, it is shaped healthily in a healthy way. You know, that's something I definitely struggled with when I first started strength training was how am I going to be?
强壮可以如此鼓舞人心。就像过去那样，“哦，别练得太肌肉发达了，别太强壮，也别太瘦。否则男人不会想要你；如果你喜欢女性，那也没人会要你。”而事实是：“其实我是为了我自己才做这些的。其他人怎么看我并不重要。对的那个人——或者也许是多个人，如果我们保持开放的选择的话——会因为我是我而爱我。他们想和我在一起是因为我很棒，而不是因为他们觉得我的外表对不对劲。”绝对的。这也是为什么强大的力量、女性运动员的展现——各种体型、身材类型的女性在运动中的曝光度如此重要，这样女孩们、我们这个年龄及更年轻的女孩们，对运动以及它能让我们做什么、能让我们感受到什么的看法，
be perceived by the people around me. Am I going to be looking sexy? Am I going to be attractive? You know, it was a really big fear that, you know, if I'm honest, kind of put me off for a while. But then, you know, growing up and seeing, you know, confident women, you know, my role models would be, you know, like Denise Lewis and seeing her. It's like, yeah, that's what I want to be. So I think role modelling and visibility is really important, you know, to contribute to that culture shift and that narrative around, you know, women being strong and women being confident, really. Yeah, and I think, you know, what can be really powerful?
才能以一种健康的方式塑造起来。这绝对是我刚开始进行力量训练时苦恼的事情：周围的人会怎么看我？我会看起来性感吗？我会很有吸引力吗？说实话，这是一个巨大的恐惧，曾一度让我退缩。但后来，随着成长并看到自信的女性，我的榜样比如丹妮丝·刘易斯（Denise Lewis），看到她时，就会觉得：“对，那就是我想成为的样子。”所以我认为，榜样作用和曝光度对于推动文化转变以及围绕“女性可以强壮、女性可以自信”的叙事真的非常重要。是的，而且我认为，什么会非常具有力量呢？
Because you're obviously speaker as an Ed Syke who's really into sport as well. Yes. How can we help you sport, not as a way of girls and young women, feeling like, oh, God, it's that should. And, you know, everyone's going to look at me and see me. I think I will say that I was raised in a era. We had to wear big gym briefs with. just a t-shirt and we had to tuck it in.
因为你显然是以一个同样非常热爱运动的教育心理学家的身份在发言。是的。我们如何帮助女孩和年轻女性看待运动时，不再觉得“天哪，这又是一个‘应该’做的事，每个人都会看着我、注意到我”？我想说，我是成长于这样一个时代的：我们必须穿着宽大的运动短裤，配上一件T恤，而且必须把T恤塞进裤子里。
That was not an easy time to be alive. That was not a good look for me. I hope that we're allowed to wear, you know, clothes now that are a little bit, a little bit more, less self-conscious making, but still for young women, as our bodies are changing, it can be really difficult to get changed, even in a changing room, to get changed and to go out there and move your body and maybe even get sweaty and, you know, to draw attention to yourself, either being good or feeling like you're not good, you know. The idea of playing rounders, like I was terrible at swinging that bat. That was not for me.
那绝对不是一段好日子，对我来说那真不是个好造型。我希望现在的女孩们被允许穿那些不那么让人自我意识过剩的衣服。不过即便如此，对于年轻女性来说，随着身体的发育，换衣服——甚至只是在更衣室里换衣服、走到外面去活动身体、甚至可能会流汗、吸引别人的注意力（无论是表现好还是觉得自己表现不好）——都会非常困难。一想到要玩板球（rounders）……我挥那个球棒简直烂透了，那根本不适合我。
You know, there's a ball coming. I have to run for it. Like, how can we try and use sport to help young girls and women to thrive in their education? Yeah, absolutely. I think over time, I've become quite passionate about sports-based interventions for children and young people, more so for those who might struggle to be engaged in academia. I think it would be, I think it is a really strong alternative. And I speak from a couple of different lenses, you know, one myself. I definitely struggled academically in the curriculum, and sports and PE was kind of the one area that I thrive, I thrived in, you know, to this day really. And one thing I always talk
你知道，球飞过来了，我还得去追。那么，我们该如何尝试利用体育运动来帮助年轻女孩和女性在教育中蓬勃发展呢？是的，绝对的。随着时间的推移，我对针对儿童和青少年的体育干预措施越来越充满热情，特别是针对那些在学业参与上可能遇到困难的孩子。我认为这是一个非常有力的替代方案。我从几个不同的角度来说明这一点：首先我自己，我在学术课程中确实很挣扎，而体育和体育课是我真正擅长、并且直到今天依然擅长的一个领域。我在教育心理学家（EP）实践中经常谈到的一点是，
about in EP practice is paying attention to the different domains and the, you know, the different areas where young people can thrive or where young people are thriving and using that to frame, you know, their educational experiences, using that as an incentive. One of the things that I have seen firsthand and, you know, I have experience is, you know, I used to work as a teaching assistant way before my EP day started, where I was involved in an enrichment initiative called Strength and Conditioning that involved bringing a group of young people to train at a gym in Birmingham with some coaches and they would be taking part in Metcon Cardio, so high intense cardio, and some weights. And we made a real effort to ensure that the group was not, you know,
要关注不同的领域，关注年轻人能够蓬勃发展或正在蓬勃发展的不同领域，并以此来构建他们的教育经历，将其作为一种激励手段。我亲眼目睹并亲身经历过的一件事是：在我的教育心理学家生涯开始很久之前，我曾担任过助教。当时我参与了一个名为“力量与体能”的课外充实计划，该计划涉及带一群年轻人到伯明翰的一家健身房，在教练的指导下进行训练。他们会参加代谢训练（Metcon）有氧运动（高强度有氧运动）和一些力量训练。我们付出了巨大努力，确保这个小组成员不是
full of students who were top of the class, who were constantly getting everything right. We were, you know, bringing pupils who struggled to engage at risk of exclusion, who weren't top of the class, who, you know, didn't get on well with teachers. And, you know, seeing them, you know, thrive. And by thrive, I mean, not only were they good at sports, but this was probably the first time I had seen them pay attention to instructions, respond well to praise and reinforcement, that for them was actually more meaningful.
那种名列前茅、凡事都能做好的优等生。我们招收的是那些参与度困难、面临被开除风险、成绩并非顶尖、与老师关系不佳的学生。看着他们蓬勃发展——我所说的“蓬勃发展”不仅指他们擅长运动，而且这可能是第一次看到他们认真听从指令、对表扬和正向强化做出良好反应，而这对他们来说实际上更有意义。
It was probably one of the few times I had seen them excited to come back. They were fully engaged, they were enjoying learning things about themselves. And those attitudes kind of carried over into the classroom because at school it was a bit like, if you kind of fall out of line, you won't be going back.
这可能是为数不多的几次，我看到他们兴奋地想要回来。他们完全投入其中，享受了解自己的过程。这种态度也延续到了教室里，因为在学校里，情况有点像：如果你有点不守规矩，你就再也来不了了。
So it was definitely a motivator for them. So that's definitely something that I champion. But sports definitely can be used in schools in various ways. You know, we look at there's a lot of talk around the PE curriculum and making sure that it's inclusive. And by that, we're thinking about flexible uniforms or flexible PE kits for our girls. In particular, you know, an example that I think about is a, young girl from a Muslim background who said, you know, she'd love to get involved in sport,
所以这绝对是他们的一大动力。这绝对是我大力倡导的做法。运动当然可以通过各种方式在学校中应用。我们看到，关于体育课程以及如何确保其包容性，有很多讨论。为此，我们考虑到为女孩提供灵活的校服或灵活的体育运动服装。特别地，我想到一个例子，一个有穆斯林背景的年轻女孩说，她很想参与运动，
but because of the way the uniform looks, she can't or it's a bit worrying for her. And so, you know, taking that into account and I've seen, I'm seeing loads of different campaigns, A6, Nike really broadening what, you know, sports wear kit, making sure, I think schools play a really big part in the narrative around sports and what it, you know, just our attitudes towards it if it's always spoken about as something on the side, not important, it doesn't have any benefits, it's, you know, it's nowhere near as serious as maths and English is it. But that narrative is fed into our pupils and then we're missing on how it can be used to enhance education. So, you know, it can be used to motivate pupils, you know, especially those who don't engage in maths, English or struggle to come to school full stop. if they can come into school and engage in a sports-based intervention before the lesson starts to help them regulate.
但因为校服的样式，她去不了，或者这让她感到有些顾虑。因此，将这一点考虑在内——我看到越来越多的不同活动，亚瑟士（ASICS）、耐克（Nike）真正扩大了运动服装系列的范围，确保……我认为学校在关于运动的叙事中扮演着非常重要的角色，包括我们对它的态度。如果它总是被当作可有可无的东西、不重要、没有任何好处，而且远不如数学和英语严肃（对吧？），这种叙事就会灌输给我们的学生，然后我们就错失了如何利用它来促进教育的机会。所以，它可以用来激励学生，尤其是那些不参与数学、英语学习，或者根本很难坚持来学校上学的学生。如果他们能在第一节课开始前参加基于运动的干预来帮助自己调节状态，
You know, that could be great. You've got our PE staff that can be used as mentors as well because they are a little bit detached from the curriculum, aren't there? They're not walking around in suits. They're more accessible and more relatable. So, you know, I'm a big fan of, you know, using PE staff. Making a PE more inclusive in terms of not making it so competitive, you know, making it a place where we are just improving our well-being, we're having fun, we are moving, we are connecting with our peers, we are developing social skills, we are developing our cognitive skills which are which is going to be important in education period. You know, these are the ways
那将是非常棒的。我们的体育老师也可以充当导师，因为他们与传统课程保持了一定距离，对吧？他们不会穿着西装走来走去，更加平易近人，也更容易产生共鸣。所以，我是体育老师的坚定支持者。让体育更具包容性，不要那么具有竞争性，让它成为一个我们只管提升健康、享受乐趣、活动身体、与同龄人建立联系、发展社交技能、发展认知技能的地方，而这些对于整个教育阶段都至关重要。这些都是
that it can be used to enhance, you know, the educational experience. It can be an outlet, you know, we release our frustrations and then we go back into class and we're good to go again. those are some definite ways. Absolutely. And I'm just thinking kind of in our very modern schools, you know, issues around ADHD and autistic girls as well. How can we use sport to optimally engage everybody? Yeah, absolutely.
可以用来提升教育体验的方法。它可以是一个宣泄口，我们释放了沮丧情绪，然后回到课堂上，就可以重新投入状态了。这些绝对都是可行的方法。完全赞同。我正在思考，在我们的现代学校里，关于多动症（ADHD）和自闭症女孩的问题也是如此。我们如何利用运动来让每个人都获得最佳的参与体验？是的，完全同意。
I guess, you know, one thing I do love at the moment or, you know, in my EP journey is working with young people who may be, who are or maybe on a pathway or who are just neurodiverse because sports is so it's structured it's safe there are clear instructions it's this or it's that and for somebody who may be ADHD for example or autistic for example this is an area where they thrive however it's not automatic you know you can't just you know send somebody with you know who may have ADHD or autism autism to go and play rugby or netball and you know they'll engage and they'll do well automatically you have to make sure that the environment is safe and structured and enough for them to
我想，目前我深爱的一点（或在我作为教育心理学家的旅程中），就是与那些被诊断或可能在诊断路径上、亦或是单纯属于神经多样性的年轻人合作。因为运动非常具有结构性、安全性，有着清晰的指令——要么这样，要么那样。对于一个可能患有多动症或自闭症的人来说，这是一个他们能够蓬勃发展的领域。然而，这并不是自动发生的。你不能只是把一个可能患有多动症或自闭症的人送去打橄榄球或无挡板篮球，然后指望他们自动投入并做得很好。你必须确保环境是安全、结构化且足够包容的，
thrive so if you think about it those who are neurodiverse may have sensory sensitivities they find environments overwhelming and sports and naturally you know can be fast and predictable it requires and smelly as well right yes smelly it requires rapid interpretation, it's unpredictable, and it can be mentally exhausting as well. So I think you have to bear in mind that we have to make sure that the environments or the, you know, the environments take those, you know, consider those things. The coaching styles are adapted as well. So for example, coaches need to ensure that their coaching style is adapted for those who may be neurodiverse. So for example, they may need to be more explicit in their guidance.
才能让他们蓬勃发展。如果你仔细想想，那些具有神经多样性的人可能会有感官敏感，他们会觉得环境令人不知所措。而体育运动自然而然地（你知道的）可能是快节奏且不可预测的，它需要……还有气味，对吧？是的，气味很大。它需要快速的解读，充满不确定性，在精神上也可能让人精疲力竭。所以我认为你必须牢记，我们必须确保环境充分考虑了这些因素。教练的风格也需要调整。例如，教练需要确保他们的执教风格适合那些具有神经多样性的人。比如，他们可能需要在指导上更加明确，
They need to make sure that their games, their sports, their, you know, activities are clearly structured and that is communicated maybe in advance. For those who are neurodiverse, that there's a lot of repetition. We can't assume that everybody just gets everything. You know, things have to be broken down. And I think, you know, especially neurodiversity in girls as well. We don't want them to come into sporting atmospheres and feel incompetent or feel, you know, that they're not welcome. They spend a lot of time masking and looking like they understand things and that they can get involved, which can lead to burnout. So we want to make sure that things are clearly structured and that they feel safe to try. So yes, there's a lot of research
他们需要确保自己的游戏、运动和活动有清晰的结构，并且这些结构最好能提前沟通。对于那些神经多样性的人来说，需要有大量的重复。我们不能假设每个人都能立刻理解所有事情，必须把事情拆解开来。而且我认为，尤其是针对女孩的神经多样性，我们不希望她们带着无能感或不受欢迎的感觉进入运动氛围。她们花了很多时间进行掩饰（masking），装作自己听懂了、能参与进去，这会导致精疲力竭。所以我们要确保事情有清晰的结构，让她们觉得尝试是安全的。是的，有很多研究
showing that sports can is a really good way for those who are neurodiverse to get involved because of the structure because of the repetition, because of the social networks and just the non-traditional ways to develop social networks and opportunities, but we just have to make sure that the conditions on our part are in place in order for them to thrive. Absolutely, absolutely. And I think if we're thinking about some of the barriers to sport, you know, cost is certainly a barrier. I really like the work that Jason Manford, the comedian, does about trying to make paddle accessible for everybody, not just kind of middle class people that have lots of money and spare time. And, you know, it's thinking about how can we try and
表明，由于运动具有结构性、重复性、社交网络以及提供非传统的社交网络和机会的方式，对于神经多样性人群来说，运动真的是一种非常好的参与方式。但我们必须确保我们做好了相应的条件准备，才能让他们蓬勃发展。完全正确，完全正确。如果我们考虑阻碍人们参与运动的一些因素，成本肯定是一个障碍。我很喜欢喜剧作家杰森·曼福德（Jason Manford）所做的工作，他致力于让板网球（padel）对每个人都触手可及，而不仅仅是那些有很多钱和闲暇时间的“中产阶级”。我们在思考，我们如何才能努力
make sport more, even things like swimming, that can be, you know, expensive. How can we try and make sport accessible for as many people as possible? Yeah, absolutely. You know, cost and being able to access sport is always going to be a huge barrier for our young people. And I think one of the ways that one of the things we think about is maybe, you know, sliding membership options. I think a lot of sports these days have a lot of, you know, fixed, you know, six weeks, six month based memberships. And, you know, if you can't afford one, you can't come back for the other six, you know, the other five weeks. And, you know, that instantly excludes a lot of people. So if we could have like sliding memberships, for example, that would be great.
让运动变得更加……甚至像游泳这样有时可能会昂贵的事情，我们如何才能努力让尽可能多的人都能参与到体育运动中呢？是的，绝对的。成本和获取运动的机会永远是我们年轻人面临的巨大障碍。我认为我们可以思考的方法之一，可能是推行“滑动阶梯式会员费”（sliding membership options）。我认为现在很多运动都采取了固定的、为期六周或六个月的会员制，如果你负担不起其中一种，你就无法在接下来的六周或五周内回来，
I think there's a lot of, you know, street games, a lot of sport Birmingham, a lot of charities really looking into how can we make sport more accessible? Is it, do we need to go around and revamp all of our basketball courts and our parks? And, you know, the answer is yes. Yeah, I think that would be an idea. Subsidized costs, yeah. Perfect, amazing.
而这瞬间就把许多人排除在外了。如果我们能采用滑动阶梯式会员费，那就太棒了。还有很多“街头运动”（street games），比如伯明翰体育（Sport Birmingham）等许多慈善机构，都在真正研究如何让运动更加普及。我们需要去翻新所有的篮球场和公园吗？答案是肯定的。是的，我觉得这是一个好主意。提供财政补贴，对吧。太棒了！
Could you tell us a bit more about you, and your work please now. So, yeah, I go by the Sporty Ed site for a couple of reasons. So I'm an educational psychologist by trade. So I'm very passionate about, you know, working with children and young people and I'm mindful of their development. And, you know, I'm passionate about ensuring that they enjoy education. They're able to access education and they're able to thrive.
能跟我们多聊聊你和你的工作吗？好的。所以，我用“运动型教育心理学家”（The Sporty Ed Psych）这个名字是有几个原因的。首先，我的本职是一名教育心理学家。我非常热衷于与儿童和年轻人工作，并且时刻关注他们的发展。我热衷于确保他们享受教育，能够接触教育并在其中茁壮成长。
But at the same time, I am very passionate about sport. I'm going to say sport, you know, as I had mentioned before, that definition has broadened. It's not just those who play football, basketball, the traditional team sports. It's broader now to include, you know, those who like to walk, those who do high rocks, athex, functional fitness, you know, it's trying to include everybody. And a couple of reasons that I, you know, kind of brought, you know, this name together is I'm very, I'm very big on bringing the two together. One, because of what it has done and offered for me,
与此同时，我也非常热爱运动。我要说的是体育运动，正如我之前提到的，这个定义已经扩大了。它不仅限于那些踢足球、打篮球等传统团队运动的人。现在的范围更广了，包括那些喜欢散步的人，做混合体能（Hyrox）、体操（calisthenics）、功能性健身的人——它试图把每个人都包容进来。我把这个名字结合在一起的几个原因之一是，我非常热衷于将这两者结合起来。首先，是因为运动为我带来的改变和赋予我的力量，
personally you know I am a strength athlete I'm very big into weightlifting I call my I go by the everyday athlete you know and just you know sports giving me the confidence I wasn't always an outspoken young you know young woman I was quite shy but sports has given me the confidence it's given me the empowerment it's given me the sense of achievement that I didn't really get from school you know I've found academia really really difficult you know And just seeing that, you know, seeing that change in myself is something that I'm really passionate about ensuring other people get the opportunity to experience as well, you know, hence the if we can edit costs so that more people can access, great. A lot of the, you know, more recently I have dabbled a lot in competitions and the competitive side of things.
我个人是一名力量举运动员，我非常热衷于举重。我称自己为“日常运动员”（everyday athlete）。运动给予了我自信，我年轻时并不是一个直言不讳的年轻女性，我其实挺害羞的。但运动赋予了我自信，赋予了我赋权感，赋予了我在学校里并没有真正获得的成就感。我发现学术研究真的非常非常困难。看到自己身上发生的这种转变，是我非常热衷于确保其他人也能有机会体验到的东西，因此，如果我们能调整成本让更多人参与进来，那就太好了。最近，我涉足了许多比赛和竞技领域。
And the more competitions that I've, you know, being involved in, the more hurdles that I've experienced both physically and mentally. and I've always kind of attached them to the principles of sports psychology, you know, hence my interest there. And one thing that I do think about a lot and I do practice is the principles from sports psychology. So if you think goal setting, visualization, you know, principles of motivation, they can be applied to the classroom to support children and young people as well. And they also support people like me, the everyday athlete.
我参与的比赛越多，在身体和心理上经历的坎坷就越多。我总是倾向于将这些经历与运动心理学（sports psychology）的原理联系起来，这也是我产生兴趣的原因。我经常思考并实践的一件事，就是运动心理学中的原则。比如目标设定、可视化、动机原理，这些原则同样可以应用到课堂中，去支持儿童和青少年。它们也支持像我这样的人——日常运动员。
you know, we're not pro, we don't get paid, we're not on TV, but we do go through the same mental struggles that pro athletes do in terms of, you know, self-belief, motivation, disengagement, body image, and therefore we need those principles as well. And so hence the sports yet, it's like it's mesh together. And so, you know, in terms of what I do, I try, well, I apply principles of sport psychology to support my young people. I'm a very big advocate for, you know, I'm a very big advocate for. for equal access to sport. You know, one of the barriers for girls is that they, one, don't have opportunity and two, they don't have the same resources that boys do, especially in school. Boys get taken on the away trips or the away matches. They have a little bit more than the grass outside
我们不是职业选手，没有报酬，也不上电视，但我们在自我信念、动力、疏离感、身体形象等方面，经历着和职业运动员完全相同的心理挣扎。因此，我们也同样需要这些原则。这就是为什么“运动型教育心理学家”这个名字把它们融合在了一起。所以，就我的工作而言，我尝试——或者说我应用运动心理学的原理来支持我的年轻人。我是……的坚定倡导者。
to explore, they get scouted out quicker than girls. You know, and I'm really passionate about ensuring that there's fairer access and making sure that, you know, ensuring that girls can tap into these benefits, you know, in a period of storm and stress and confusion and identity, you know, and just having fun with it. I think I'm very big on sports in school being seen as fun and enjoyment, as well as it being an opportunity to find a strength that we can use to help you further engage in school or a career pathway or, you know, finding out a different
倡导体育运动的平等获取。女孩们面临的障碍之一是，她们一方面缺乏机会，另一方面没有男孩拥有的同等资源，尤其是在学校里。男孩们会被带去参加客场旅行或客场比赛。除了外面的草坪，他们有更多可以探索的空间，他们被球探发现的速度也比女孩更快。我非常热衷于确保更公平的获取机会，并确保女孩们能够在暴风雨、压力、困惑和身份认同的时期，享受到这些运动带来的好处，并在其中收获快乐。我认为我非常坚定地主张，学校里的体育运动应该被视作一种乐趣和享受，同时也是一个发现自身优势的机会，我们可以利用这些优势帮助她们更好地融入学校、找到职业发展路径，或者探索不同的方向。
part of your identity, you know, especially around, you know, young people who have a really bad narrative at school. It's really nice to find, you know, something, sport or maybe not, that they are excelling at and bringing that to the forefront. And so that is a bit of me. That is what I do. Yeah, amazing. Thank you. And it's making me think about when I was at school, like the tennis courts were never used by girls at lunchtime and break times. They were commandeered by boys to play football on. And I guess it's thinking about equity. So it's actually thinking about, you know,
这是你身份的一部分，你知道的，特别是对那些在学校里有着非常糟糕经历的年轻人来说。找到一些他们擅长的东西——无论是运动还是别的什么——并将其展现出来，这真的是一件很美好的事。这就是我的一部分，这就是我所做的。是的，太棒了。谢谢你。这让我想起了我在学校的时候，比如午休和课间休息时，网球场从来没有女生用过。它们都被男生霸占去踢足球了。我想这就是在思考公平问题。所以实际上是在思考，你知道的，
obviously I think maybe there's perhaps more female football players now than there were when I was at school. But also, you know, what if, you know, someone wants to actually play tennis or netball or do something different, you know, there's got to be the equitable opportunities in schools for those, I think they're multi-use games areas now, aren't they? But I know that my year eight son, so he's 12 years old, I know that every lunch and break, he is out on the mugger playing football, but how, you know,
显然，我觉得现在女足球员可能比我上学时要多。但同时，如果有人真的想打网球、无板篮球或做点别的什么呢？学校必须为这些提供公平的机会，我想现在它们被称为多功能运动区吧？不过我知道我读八年级的儿子，也就是12岁，我知道他每个午休和课间都在多功能运动区踢足球，但是，
how are schools facilitating or how could they facilitate making that fairer so that it's not just commandeered by the boys, I guess. Maybe, you know, someone listening to this or watching this might be able to think, oh yeah, yeah, we could maybe do that a little bit differently. Yeah, I think that's really important because, you know, our girls need exposure, you know, to these opportunities. You know, they might try and they might be amazing. They might try and might never do it again. But I think that equality, you know, of exposure is so important. And maybe schools need to be looking at one, provide, looking how they can provide more of a range so that both boys and girls more so are able to experience different types of
学校是如何促进或者说他们怎么能促进这种公平，让它不被男生独占呢？也许，听节目或看节目的某个人可能会想，哦，是的，是的，我们也许可以稍微做点不同的尝试。是的，我认为这非常重要，因为，你知道的，我们的女孩需要接触这些机会。你知道的，她们可能会去尝试，然后发现自己棒极了。她们也可能尝试之后再也不去了。但我认为这种接触机会的平等是如此重要。也许学校需要审视第一点，思考如何提供更多样化的活动，让男生和女生都能更多地体验不同类型的
activities. It might be some kind of list or wait list where teachers are picking out who gets to use certain facilities. Maybe it's a girls only session on one day and the boys only session on another day and then a mixed session on the day after. Just being more mindful about, you know, opportunity and I think we do need to have our hand a bit more, especially in schools about, you know, who gets access to the opportunities just to make sure that it's fair. I don't think that we can just leave it. You know, we build a new basketball court and it's free for all because it will be dominated by boys. We do have to put, we do have to take a bit response, a bit more responsibility with this and and really kind of scaffold, you know, who, what times can we bring in
活动。可能是某种名单或候补名单，由老师来挑选谁可以使用某些设施。也许某一天是仅限女生的课程，另一天是仅限男生的课程，再之后一天是男女混合课程。对机会有更多的意识，而且我认为我们确实需要在学校里更多地介入，关于谁能获得这些机会，以确保它是公平的。我认为我们不能顺其自然。我们建了一个新的篮球场然后对所有人开放，因为最后它肯定会被男生主导。我们必须承担起更多的责任，真正去引导，比如什么时间我们可以引入
different role models, different, you know, female coaches, if, you know, because that might be a thing as well, you know, a lot of girls get put off if it's like a male coach because they're like, you know, how can I express myself and do I feel safe to? Might be more female coaches, but definitely having a hand in kind of manipulating almost who gets access to what. Absolutely. Such brilliant, brilliant ideas now. Where can people learn more about you and your work? If you want to learn more about me, I'm on LinkedIn under Melissa Morrison, the Sporty Ed Syke, and I'm on Instagram, Melissa Morrison 193, until my website comes along, which is very soon. But those are the best ways to engage with me.
不同的榜样，不同的女教练，如果可以的话，因为这也是一个因素，你知道的，很多女孩如果面对男教练可能会觉得扫兴，因为她们会想，我该如何表达自己？我感到安全吗？可能会有更多女教练，但绝对需要介入并在某种程度上“操纵”谁能获得什么权限。绝对是这样。真是太棒、太棒的主意了。那么人们在哪里可以更多地了解你和你的工作呢？如果你想了解我，我在领英上叫梅利莎·莫里森，也就是“运动教育心理学家”，我在Instagram上的账号是梅利莎·莫里森193，直到我的网站上线为止，那个很快就会好。但这些是与我互动的最佳方式。
Thank you so much for your time and sharing your wisdom with our audience. It's so important. So thank you so much. Thank you for having me. You're more than welcome. Thank you so much again to Dr Mel, aka the sporty ed psych. Please do go and follow her on LinkedIn. I'm speaking to you when it's been continuing to rain in the UK currently for 42 days in a row. Wow we, that's a lot. And I am actually kind of embracing it. I'm still going to outside exercise classes. You just kind of wrap up warm and
非常感谢你抽出时间与我们的听众分享你的智慧。这太重要了。所以非常感谢。谢谢你邀请我。不用谢。再次非常感谢梅尔博士，也就是运动教育心理学家。请大家一定要去领英上关注她。我是在英国连续下雨42天的背景下跟你们录音的。天哪，雨真多。我其实已经在试着接受它了。我还是会去参加户外的运动课。你只需要穿得暖和一点，
make sure there's a shower available at the end. It's making me feel chilly just to think about it. How do you keep yourself active and moving? How do you honour your own body? I would love to know. Please do drop me a comment or connect with me on social media and let me know. If you find this episode helpful, inspiring, encouraging, please do consider sharing it to your stories on social media and tag me too. That would be so appreciated.
确保结束后有淋浴可用就行。光是想想就觉得有点冷。你是如何保持活跃和运动的？你是如何善待自己的身体的？我很想知道。请给我留言或在社交媒体上与我联系并告诉我。如果你觉得这期节目有帮助、有启发、有鼓励，请考虑把它分享到你社交媒体的故事中，并@我。那将是对我莫大的支持。
And if you can share us more publicly on your social media, I would love that too. I'm a psychologist and I'm a psychological practitioner from Newcast I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the rain. of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate. And it's been really
如果你能在社交媒体上公开分享我们，我会更高兴的。我是一名心理学家，也是来自纽卡斯尔的心理治疗师。我只想向《临床心理学家集锦》一书的撰稿人们表达最真挚的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，并很喜欢深入了解大家的各种背景和经历。人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的经历。这真的非常
interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate. But this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot. So the biggest thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有趣，也让我看到了申请潜在的障碍以及我如何能尝试绕过这些障碍。我曾经真的很怀疑自己，不知道自己是否有资格申请临床心理学博士学位。但这确实给了我放手一搏所需的信心。所以我要表达最真挚的感谢。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。